gradient checking this technique this
helped me save tons of time and help me
find bugs in my implementation of
backpropagation many times let's see how
you can use it to to debug or to verify
that your implementation of that top is
correct so your new network will have
some set of parameters W 1 V 1 and so on
up to WL PL so to implement gradient
checking the first thing you should do
is take all your parameters and reshape
them into a giant vector theta so so
what you should do is take W which is a
matrix and reshape it into a vector
you'll take all of these WS and reshape
them into vectors and then concatenate
all of these things so that you have a
giant vector theta giant vector
parameters theta so instead of a cost
function J being a function of you know
the W's and B's you will now have the
cost function J being just a function of
theta mixed with W and be ordered the
same way you can also take DW 1 DB 1 and
so on and reshape them into Big John
vector D theta of the same dimension as
theta right so same as before reshape DW
1 into the matrix EB ones already vector
reshape dwl all the DWS which are
matrices remember DW 1 has the same
dimension as W 1 DB 1 is sin which the B
1 so the same sort of reshaping and
concatenation operation you can then
reshape all of these derivatives into a
giant vector D theta which is same
dimension as theta so the question is
now is D theta the gradient or the slope
of the cost function J so just how you
implement gradient checking and often
abbreviate gradient checking into grande
check so first remember that J is now a
function of the giant parameter theta
right so you can also expand without the
J is a function of theta 1 theta 2 theta
3 and so on right however whatever the
dimension of this giant parameter vector
theta
so the implement drag check what you're
going to do is implement a loop so that
for each I so each component of data
let's compute D theta aprox I to be and
we're going to take a two sided
difference so I take J of theta theta 1
theta 2 up to theta I and we're going to
nudge theta I to add epsilon to this so
just you know increase play the I by
epsilon and keep everything all the same
and because it taking a two-sided
difference we're going to do the same on
the other side will stay to open now
minus epsilon and then all of the other
elements of theta are left alone and
then we'll take this and we divided by 2
theta and what we saw on from the
previous video is that this should be
approximately equal to D theta I which
which is supposed to be the partial
derivative of G with respect to I guess
data I if D theta I is you know the
derivative of the cost function J so
what you're going to do is you're going
to compute this for every value of I and
at the end you now end up with two
vectors you end up with this D theta
aprox and this is going to be the same
dimension as D theta and both of these
are in turn the same dimension as theta
and what you want to do is check of
these vectors are approximately equal to
each other so in detail well how do you
define whether or not two vectors are
really reasonably close to each other
what I do is the following on I would
compute the Euclidean distance between
these two vectors D theta aprox minus D
theta so just - OH - normal this notice
there's no square on top so this is the
sum of squares of elements of the
differences and then you take a square
root to get the Euclidean distance and
then just to normalize by the lengths of
these vectors are divided by D theta
aprox
plus D theta just take the Euclidean
length or from the defectors
the role for the denominators just in
case any of these vectors in really
small a really large you know the
denominator turns this formula
interracial so when you implement this
in practice I use epsilon equals maybe
10 to the minus 7 so you know one year
minus seven and with this range of
epsilon if you find that this formula
gives you a value like ten to the minus
seven or smaller then that's great
it means that your derivative
approximation is very likely correct now
this is just very small value it is
maybe on the range of ten to the minus
five I would take a careful look maybe
this is okay but I might double check
the components of this vector and make
sure that none of the components are to
launch and some of the components of
this difference are very large there may
be other bug somewhere and if this
formula on the left is you know on the
order of ten to the minus three then I
would worry it would be much more
concerned that maybe there's a bug
somewhere but you should really be
getting values much smaller than 10
minus vo and if there's any bigger than
10 to minus C then I would be quite
concerned I was seriously worried about
whether or not there's about and I would
then you should then look at the
individual components of theta to see
you know if there's a specific value of
I for which D theta cross I is very
different from D theta I and use that to
try to track down whether or not some of
your derivative computations might be
incorrect and after some amount of
debugging if finally it ends up being
this kind of very small value then you
probably have a correct implementation
so when implementing your network will
often happen as results in plan for
problems and back prop and then I might
find that this graduate gives a
relatively big value in and I was
suspected it must be a bug go in debug
debug debug and after debugging for a
while if I find it a partial strand
check with a small value then you know
you can be much more confident that is
them correct so you now know how a
gradient checking works doesn't help me
find lots of both in my implementations
at neural nets and I hope will help you
too
in the next video I want to share you
some tips or some notes on how to
actually implement gradient checking
let's go onto the next video